if you're going to have interaction with
someone you stab them in the back or do
you cooperate or and your starting point
is you're never going to see this person
again and they have no means of telling
anyone else on Earth if you were a jerk
or whatever the only real politic thing
that anyone could ever do is don't
cooperates to have them in the back if
you have only one round that you're
going to interact with and then you get
this horrible regressive thing that if
you're going to interact with them for
two rounds what's the logical thing to
do on the second round stab them in the
back so you've already defaulted into no
that the second round is going to be
non-cooperation so what do you do in the
first round you already know the second
round is a given so you might as well
stab them in the back on the first one
and if there's three rounds you go
backwards and at every one of those
points if you're hyper rational no
matter how many rounds ahead of you
there are if you know how many there are
going to be the only like uber spocky
and logical thing to do is to never ever
cooperate where the Breakthrough comes
in is when you don't know how many
rounds there are in the future